the world's largest asset manager is
doubling down on crypto filings now show
Black Rock is taking its first steps to
launch a spot ethereum ETF according to
Delaware's Division of Corporations
website The Firm has submitted an i
shares ethereum trust for regulatory
approval so let's look at ethereum so
yesterday the token you can see right
here spiked it is up over 10% since just
two days ago Bitcoin also got a boost on
the ethereum news because Black Rock
obviously is very powerful it is also
one of the 12 applicants waiting on the
SEC to approve a spot Bitcoin ETF here
in a fox business exclusive is po
Investments investor Anthony Pompano who
also served as a sergeant in the US Army
infantry thank you every day for your
service pomp but uh ethereum and here
comes Larry think the ey shares team and
black rock saying all right as we wait
for the Bitcoin spot ETF to be approved
we're going in on ether what did you
think of that news well first of all
thank you for having me um when you're
contrarian in order to get financial
Returns the contrarian bet has to become
a consensus bet and that's what we're
watching play out right here is for
years we have seen investors mainly
retail um go and bet on assets that were
outside of the Legacy Financial system
now all of a sudden we're seeing Black
Rock and many other large Financial
organizations say we don't want to be
left behind we want to play this game as
well and so as they show up and they
start to incorporate these assets into
their funds and other types of uh
investment offerings you're going to see
that contrarian bet become consensus
Capital will flow in and prices will go
up do you think there's enough interest
in ether per se I think that people are
drastically underestimating how big the
entire crypto Market is going to get
Bitcoin will remain the king of that
market but many of these assets are
going to get much much bigger and will
be measured I believe in tens of
trillions of dollars across the entire
crypto Market the SEC has been immovable
so far on approving a spot Bitcoin ETF
and there are as we said a bunch of
names circling and waiting do you sit
there and and parse and think to
yourself who might get the first
approval because on the screen you see
Fidelity Wisdom Tree Arc bitwise not
just black rock grayscale vanc Etc and I
I want to see your face when you answer
this question who is going to get the
nod first I don't lay away I don't lay
awake at night thinking about that all
12 of them definitely do uh CU there's
billions of dollars in assets uh at
stake here what I think we should do is
we should approve all of them at the
exact same time we don't need Regulators
playing you know um a kind of kingmaker
right this is not the UK where we're
nighting people and saying you're the
winner or you're the winner let the free
market decide it approve all of them and
the market will decide where those
assets will flow and that seems the Fair
Way Gary Gensler in the SEC would just
say okay all 12 of you go for it I I
think that it's actually a pretty
interesting way to absolve them of
having to make the decision and if you
just let the market go ahead and do it
then now all of a sudden it's a fair
game whoever ends up being the winner
you can just point say the market
decided this is where the assets wanted
to flow and so it just resolves a lot of
potential problems that could be on
their hands I feel like it's going to be
Ark and Kathy would I don't know why and
I only say that because I I don't know
if Gary kinler wants to say here Larry
think and why not black rock is great at
what it does but it just feels like DC
is nervous about that type of stuff um
let's talk about Bitcoin the price of it
pops every time there is news of that
possibility we're now at above 37,000 I
think at last check we were 37,2 n it's
rallied up 125% this year now JP Morgan
analysts say it's overdone but of course
they're talking their boss's game Jamie
Diamond has never liked crypto my guess
is that uh a lot of these people are
looking at the short-term volatility
right I love the volatility I want more
volatility and the reason is because
volatility over a long period of time
actually leads to outsize returns if you
want asymmetry which has largely been
kind of arbed out of the market in most
other assets there's no volatility in
these other assets there's no
outperformance in these other assets
Bitcoin allows for investors to allocate
Capital to an investment that they can
audit at any time that they can put
billions of dollars into and it can
drive a semester returns and that's what
we've seen this thing has compounded at
tens of percent a year for over a decade
right now in the last 3 months 88% of
Bitcoin in circulation has not moved in
the last year More than 70% of Bitcoin
has not moved they're going to approve
this ETF we're going to return to loose
monetary policy we're going to get to
having next year and this thing is going
to fly just like it did back in 2021
great to see you pomp thank you so much
Anthony Pomp leano and and pomp isn't
just a warrior in the crypto trenches as
we said he served as a sergeant in the
US Army infantry oh look at that where
was that picture taken uh that is in
tajia rock wow thank you thank you for
all of what you and your comrades have
done we really appreciate it